non on travaille sur les c'est le
président de la République euh autour du
mois de novembre m'a chargé d'une
mission euh pour euh proposer une une
évolution euh de la décentralisation un
approfondissement de la décentralisation
aujourd'hui euh personne n'est content
quand vous faites le tour des grandes
associations euh d'élus euh on n'est pas
content les les les maires sont pas
contents euh la loi 3DS la loit 3DS a
été une dé c'est des aajustements c'est
c'est c'est une loi importante une bonne
partie d'ailleurs n'est pas appliqué au
fond les élus ne s'en saisissent pas bon
donc en tout cas dire que la loi de la
fin de l'année pas que des ajustements
ce sera une
vérit c'est pas du tout desjustements
c'est une loi d'approfondissement de la
décentralisation ce serait ça une ou des
je ne sais pas on verra on n'est pas
encore à la fin de l'année et loin de là
on y travaille la forme juridique j'en
sais rien je le gouvernement verra en
fonction des propositions ce qui est
très très important c'est c'est au fond
d'améliorer la production du service
local la production du service local
c'est le service tel qu'il est produit
pour les concitoyens est-ce qu'il est
bien produit est-ce qu'il est mal
produit il faut regarder les questions
de moyens beaucoup d'élus se plaignent
euh de de de d'absence de de moyens euh
l'État leur dit mais des moyens on en a
donné beaucoup regardez pendant le covid
on a été l'assureur de tout on était
l'assureur des salariés l'assureur des
entreprises l'assureur des collectivités
locales donc il faut aussi regarder ce
qui relève en réalité de la libre
administration des collectivités locales
c'estd non mais concrètement
concrètement ça veut dire quoi Eric
est-ce que ça veut dire parce que là
notamment les maires disent qu'ils n'ont
plus de de pouvoir fiscal avec la
suppression de la la taxe d'habitation
est-ce qu'il faut redonner un appau
fléché sur la libre la libre
administration ça veut dire que lorsque
vous êtes responsable de d'une politique
du la mise en œuvre de l'organisation
d'une d'une politique soit une politique
sociale ou d'urbanisme ou de sécurité
lorsque vous en êtes responsable et que
l'État a acté le fait que c'était pas
lui qui s'en occupait directement mais
que c'était vous commune
intercommunalité département ou ou
région et bien alors là l'élu local il
exerce à plein son pouvoir il il il
décide de l'organisation de cette
politique il peut en décider d'ailleurs
différemment qu'on soit au nord ou au
sud et puis également il il
l'organise totalement donc ça c'est pas
complèement vra concrtement qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire est-ce que ça veut dire
un nouvel impôt pour que les élus aent
des ressources propres alors il y a il y
a la question de la fiscalité la fin de
la taxe d'habitation elle a été actée
elle a été votée par Assemblée nationale
et par et par le Sénat bien sûr que non
enfin ce sera alors ce serait le ce
serait le le le pompon de
l'impuissance politique vous décidez un
truc et puis 3 mois après 1 an après 2
ans après ou 3 ans après vous revenez
vous revenez là-dessus je pense que
c'était une mesure chacun au Sénat on en
a parlé on
l' bah moi j'avais mon opinion de de
l'époque elle est clairement elle était
clairement affichée mais ça a été fait
donc c'est PRAG moi moi j'ai un esprit
pragmatique on va pas passer son temps à
refaire ce qui a déjà été éé
fait oui mais on peut réfléchir aussi
autrement on peut réfléchir autrement à
l'évolution des finances locales pour
qu' de l'économie on peut réfléchir il y
a des partages d'impôts nationaux
aujourd'hui la TVA est un impôt qui est
largement partagé par par aux
collectivités la télva l'État en perçoit
euh grosso modo moins de 50 %
aujourd'hui est-ce que on l'a fait de
manière consciente et cohérente non donc
est-ce qu'on peut remettre de la
cohérence sur tout cela et ça c'est très
important est-ce qu'on peut aussi ça
Veer d'autres impôts nationaux vers les
collectivités est-ce qu'on peut aussi
rattacher les ressources locales à la
nature des charges qu'elles ont un
département il a beaucoup de charges
sociales une une région elle a beaucoup
de de charges dans le domaine de de
l'équipement des des
infrastructures ch une charge
infinancement c'est ça la clarté
normalement oui mais c'est d'ailleurs le
premier ministre l'a évoqué une charge
infinancement ou au moins un financement
qui euh qui a qui a un lien avec
l'évolution de cette charge et et qui ne
soit pas contrraacyclique c'estàd qu'en
même temps vous voyez la baisse de vos
recettes et une augmentation de vos de
vos de vos dépenses c'est le cas par
exemple pour les départements quand ils
ont des droits de mutation bah ça
s'effondre ça a beaucoup augmenter mais
en ce moment ça ça baisse plutôt et et
et en même temps il les charges de leur
prestation social augmenter ces charges
de prestation sociales elles sont par
elles-mêmes définies par l'État et donc
chacun doit être responsable de ce qu'il
choisit l'État doit être responsable de
l'égalité devant les citoyens on peut
pas verser un RSA différent au Nord
comme au Sud ni une pration
compensatrice du handicap il faut le
faire donc l'État doit exercer cette
responsabilité et l'assumer et le
défendre et les les les départements
sont chargés de la mise en œuvre de
cette poli comment on fait pour que
chacun y voit plus
[Musique]